[Music]
with fast and furious 10 also known as
fast x the penultimate part of one of
the most successful movie series of all
time will be released in theaters next
year in today's video we will be
discussing the potential plot the
already huge cast and the ongoing
production this video will give you a
complete update on all the latest news
so enjoy our new original
before talking about a possible
storyline for fast x we should take a
closer look at its immediate predecessor
fast and furious none thus there is of
course a risk of spoilers here the movie
starts with a flashback to the life of
dom torred on his brother jacob who is
unknown to us until then after a tragic
accident of their father in his race car
dom accused his brother of having
deliberately manipulated the father's
car the latter though insists that he
has not done anything that was not
previously agreed upon with her father
jacob eventually has to leave town after
losing a car race and away from don and
his sister mia he develops into a
skilled thief killer and of course
driver many years later dom and his crew
encounter the long disappeared jacob
while on a rescue mission he probably
grabs a device recovered from a plane
wreck and flees this device turns out to
be project aries consisting of two parts
and a matching key that can be used to
shut down online communications
worldwide dom eventually pursues a lead
to great britain where jacob is supposed
to be staying taking the teacher to
london dom ramsey roman and dash finally
track him down in scotland's capital
edinburgh they're using technical
know-how he also succeeds in taking the
second part of project ares however he's
caught trying to escape and is held
captive and missed a nobody's hideout as
it turns out jacob wasn't trusted by mr
nobody to secure project aries after the
events of the fast and the furious tokyo
drift while attempting to recover it the
two scientists who developed the device
both died and it becomes apparent that
their daughter l is the missing key to
project aries jacob's mercenary seem to
have only been waiting for this moment
as they storm the hideout and free ellen
her boss while roman and tatch are
supposed to destroy a crucial satellite
in space another encounter between
dumb's crew and jacob reveals that the
lattice partner otto is actually working
for the cyber terrorist cipher
eventually jacob decides to side with
his brother and with some luck taj and
roman succeed in destroying this
satellite before the upload of project
aries is completed in the end there is a
happy ending after all and jacob is able
to escape with the help of dom and his
car besides during the credits you can
see han who was presumed dead it's not
that easy to make guesses regarding the
plot of fast and furious 10 after all is
neither official information about the
story nor a first trailer the
interesting aspect of the film series
however is that just about anything is
possible as we saw in the ninth part not
even outer space is left out as an
action-packed setting so how does the
fast and furious team plan to go the
extra mile maybe they don't even have to
as the focus has always been on the
family like dumb never ceases to point
out it is therefore quite possible that
they will slowly but surely hand over
the reins to the next generation in
parts 10 and 11. at least mia actress
jodena brewster has already suggested
something similar in the past we also
know from an instagram video of vin
diesel from may 30th that they want to
return to the roots of the franchise
diesel and his colleague tyrese gibson
can be seen standing in the fabled
garage of the first part but does this
really mean that we will see more petty
crime car racing and less mission
impossible like action again in fact
it's doubtful after all a return to the
roots could simply mean the toretto
family's roots which recently gained
another family member in the form of
grandma toretto taking distance from the
over-the-top action in the final stages
does not sound like fast and furious at
all another important story aspect is of
course the villains that show up it is
considered likely that charlize theron
cipher will once again serve as the
antagonist particularly after her
elaborate plan failed again the
terrorists will surely have a bone to
pick with dominus crew apart from cypher
we firmly anticipate the return of
daggett shaw from fast and furious 7
since his comeback was already hinted at
in the mid-credits scene of the last
part this is where jason momoa could
also come into play because this still
unknown character of the 42nd year old
is supposed to be an extremely
extravagant and eye-catching villain
according to his own statement due to
the huge popularity of the aquaman star
he will no doubt end up being the
ultimate bad guy if you look at the
previous movies the villains actually
became nastier more cunning and
increasingly dangerous momoa being the
leader of the pack is therefore the only
logical conclusion although he certainly
will not be the only one to take on dom
and his friends
next we would like to give you a brief
overview of the gigantic cast we know
for sure that vin diesel will be back as
dom toretto michelle rodriguez has his
wife letty ludacris as tash parker
terry's gibson as roman jodena
brewster's dumb sister mia toretto and
nathalie emmanuel as ramsay other cast
members include song kang as han liu
scotties would ask little nobody michael
rooker as buddy cardi b as lisa and
charlie's theron as cipher also recently
announced was the signing of 90 year old
hollywood legend rita moreno asked
granny toretto in still unknown roles
there are jason momoa as well as the
suicide squad star daniela melkeorg
captain marvel actress perry larsen and
reacher actor alan richson there's
already talk of brie larson in
particular as the 32 year old is rumored
to be taking on the role of the missing
sister of brian or connor who was played
by paul walker up until his death either
way it is considered likely that walker
will be given a proper tribute perhaps
the most controversial character
meanwhile is dwayne johnson's luke hopps
at the end of last year vin diesel
desperately tried to convince johnson
via instagram to come back in order for
him to fulfill his destiny diesel also
dragged his children into it as well as
the late paul walker which johnson did
not appreciate at all the latter
confirmed in an interview with the cnn
that he considered diesel's attempt to
be highly manipulative and there will be
zero chance of him returning to the film
series although vin diesel has tried
everything to persuade johnson it seems
that the conflict between the two rather
stubborn actors was still too profound
nevertheless we can certainly look
forward to more luke hopscott and in the
future
since the spin-off hops in shaw is not a
part of the main series and many people
are expecting a further spin-off in the
future according to media reports the
most recent edition is us comedian pete
davidson so far so good however he drew
attention in 2015 by making a crude joke
about paul walker's accidental death
behind the scenes this is now causing
resentment as many of the actors
involved first expect a public apology
before working with a 28 year old
however there may also have been some
sort of internal deal as davidson is not
exactly known for justifying his jokes
which is a tricky subject for a comedian
anyway
filming of fast and furious 10 began
last april starting in london the
production is taking place back to back
by the way which means that the last
part fast and furious 11 is being shot
at the same time soon after filming
began director justin lin quit
reportedly due to differences regarding
the creative side of things many
speculate that vin diesel might have got
something to do with it it is widely
known that diesel wants to have the
scene almost everything and that he's
not easily willing to compromise as one
knows from insider sources vin diesel
regularly causes head shaking on the set
for instance he is reported to often not
know his lines be physically out of
shape and show up late justin lin
moreover has certainly not given up the
high paying director's job which
certainly pays on the 8-digit range for
no valid reason regardless the franchise
legend is at least still involved as a
producer the process of finding a new
director proved to be extremely
difficult and it is estimated that the
fast and furious crew lost around 1
million for each day of shooting they
lost on the discussion were among others
hobbs and shaw director david leach and
fast and furious 8th director f gary
gray in the end the choice of the
responsible parties fell on someone who
had nothing to do with the franchise
namely frenchman louis letterier who has
directed films such as now you see me
and the transporter with great success
provided that filming goes smoothly in
all other respects it can be assumed
that fast and furious 10 will be
released in movie theaters on may 19
2023
are you looking forward to fast x or did
you stop following the action franchise
a long time ago feel free to share your
expectations and opinions in the
comments see you next time
[Music]
you